was this cast sort of divided by those
who had to show up for work five hours
early for makeup and those who did not
we never we never talked to them yeah
what are you that's like when you see
somebody who doesn't have to go through
that at the end of the day when they're
like oh man today was brutal yeah well
genuinely I would you know I get picked
up at 2:50 a.m. so I probably woken up
at 2:00 a.m. whatever I come in I do my
for an hour and no I always wake up have
breakfast do my thing yeah yeah
I love actors just get up and just get
out I kind of need to go through my my
process yeah but why was I doing that in
fact I should have done pick up that's a
245 so but I would come out of all this
process and I'd see Harris Dickinson or
whatever and he'd be like morning mate
you just got picked up did you just got
brought in but again I bring it back to
the notion that is it worth it she was
that early wake up was the four nine
thousand four steaks worth it and yes it
was yeah you know I don't want to do it
every movie right but it was worth day
and it was necessary and it was perfect
for this movie
the idea of having Michelle Pfeiffer an
Angelina Jolie in a movie and yet doing
battle in a movie when those moments
were happening what was the mood like
when you knew it was gonna go down with
everybody
I mean we were separate in in some
senses that a lot the time we were kind
of in our favor all right
um but you had to want to be there
that's not something you want to miss
generally right that's true yeah it was
great these characters are so iconic
yeah as well as the actresses are so
iconic you just that obviously it's
really exciting to kind of see them you
know you know in battle in this way but
also it's such an inversion of all of
the kind of the sort of tropes and
fairytale tropes and these you know that
I mean the fairytale trope both from
Maleficent and that trope of the Wicked
Witch but also for the Queen you know
the fairy tale yeah it's so you know
michelle has taken in as such a
completely different direction and the
story does as well and so you know just
all of that strength and fire and you
know it's like it's really powerful and
so they're both just these incredibly
powerful characters and it's just and
that makes it very very rich you know
before I let you go do you guys have
kids in your lives because I imagine
it's moments like this where you get to
be the hero right the big shot come see
what I do I mean you're definitely the
hero I mean I don't want to say too much
but um yeah bit concerned about
terrifying my young people in my life
of course it's wonderful to be able to
enter that kind of demographic yeah
cinema then a demographic me and you
know to Attell have done a lot of things
that couldn't be worse my children and
you know we've we've
[Laughter]
but um you know so it is of course a joy
to be able to UM to work in this this
demographic the Disney demographic run
wonderful absolute pleasure